merci michel et merci c'est le mot qui
vient spontanément aux lèvres merci
merci d'abord à michel de son accueil de
son organisation sa capacité à
rassembler sa capacité à faire que
l'accueil pour laurent et françois
xavier soit à la hauteur du niveau
qu'ils ont mis dans la barque ils ont
mis très haute
merci bien sûr à tous les élus qui sont
là je le remercie bien sûr dominique
charles anges erick christian henry
monsieur le sénateur vous tous je vais
pas citer les élus ce qui est important
c'est que vous soyez là vous des autres
voilà tous ceux qui ont choisi de passer
à un moment avec nous et que vous soyez
là depuis le début
traversant la tempête avec votre
solidité où que vous soyez revenus ce
qui est important c'est que vous soyez
là ce qui est important c'est que cette
famille soit rassemblée et s'il ya un
merci à dire un merci à dire à une
personne s'est alors ans que je le dis
merci parce que dans la division je
dirais presque dans la dispersion dans
laquelle nous nous sommes trouvés il
était facile de sombrer dans le
désespoir ou pire dans le fatalisme
après tout qui se débrouille après tout
ceux qui sont allés en face qu'ils
aillent en face après tout ceux qui sont
restés à la maison qui vont rester à la
maison qui reste à la maison et laurent
tu as eu le courage de dire et la
volonté de fer et ces éléments là sont
des éléments majeurs pour un chef
on s'invente pas chef il ya un moment où
lorsque le désert existe lorsque le
calot existe parce que la défaite vient
des soufflets l'ensemble de toutes les
bonnes volontés il ya quelqu'un qui se
dresse et qui dit or on y va on y
retourne
et bien c'est laurent qui l'a fait il a
fait en rassemblant la première preuve
du rassemblement si j'ose dire laurent
et pardonne-moi 7e éléments c'est qui il
m'a tendu la main n'avons pas toujours
dit les mêmes choses n'avons pas
toujours utilisé les mêmes mots mais
nous avons toujours eu la même loyauté
vis-à-vis de notre famille politique
vous êtes notre famille politique et
dans votre diversité nous avons l'union
ensemble et cette diversité est la
garante justement la garante de notre
force retrouvée
merci merci aussi d'avoir réfléchi à un
projet avant de poser en termes simples
le fait de dire et qui va être le leader
parce que c'était bien la question
dis moi un non et non je vais te dire
une idée la politique ce n'est pas
uniquement une ambition personnelle et
je dirais que françois-xavier n'avait
rien demandé
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il réussit
mieux que les autres aujourd'hui parce
qu'il n'a pas frappé à la porte pendant
des heures et des heures pour dire c'est
moi et pas les autres
le projet d'abord ce projet nous l'avons
vécu ensemble et pas loin
nous l'avons vécu à menton je cherche
monsieur le maire de menton
nous l'avons vécu à menton merci jean
claude et nous avons défini sept piliers
et des sept piliers commencer par un mot
nous sommes européens parce que nous
sommes français et cet engagement
européen
mettez fin à toute polémique sur le fait
de savoir si nous devions défaire ou
déconstruire non nous voulons construire
construire notre parti c'est partiel
c'est partial construire notre pays
c'est un projet construire l'europe est
notre pays à l'intérieur de l'europe
alors là c'est un engagement oui on
commence par dire nous sommes européens
et puis donc disons des choses simples
il y a des frontières c'est pas des murs
et frontières parce que les uns veulent
se protéger des autres
ils mettent des murs rappelez vous de ce
mur de berlin qui a changé lorsqu'il est
tombé et qui a ouvert le mondre le monde
communiste au monde libre
et bien non la frontière ça dit tu es
différent de moi et je respecte ta
culture et je respecte à civilisation
mais ma frontière fait que je sais qui
je suis et je vais vers toi la main
tendu la main ferme est ouverte mais la
main tendue c'est ça la frontière eh
bien oui nous sommes pour les frontières
et puis et pardonnez du peu
nous sommes pour protéger les européens
quelle drôle d'idée
comment une mère quand il se fait élire
il dit je protègerai mes concitoyens une
région et le dis je protègerai ma région
le président de la france devrait dire
devrait dire je protège des français
et quand on se présente à l'europe on
vous doit dire je proposais protège
l'europe et je protège l'europe contre
la concurrence déloyale
je protège l'europe contre l'immigration
ou violentes je protège l'europe parce
que c'est ma civilisation
le mot civilisation est posée et nous
savons depuis paul valéry qu'elles sont
mortelles et nous savons que la note est
en danger et que nous savons que la note
est en danger non pas parce qu'elle est
en conflit avec d'autres
mais parce qu'elle a peine à s'affirmer
quelle drôle de monde et quelle drôle de
société dans laquelle on a presque honte
d'être ce que nous sommes presque honte
de dire oui ce monde comme le disait
camus cette civilisation européenne a
été formulée sur deux grands piliers
le premier c'est la raison la raison
cartésienne cherche françois-xavier
cette raison cartésienne qui nous a fait
avancer dans les techniques dans la
science et faire en sorte que nous avons
dominé le monde
excusez-nous d'avoir dominé le monde par
la technique par la science excusez-nous
d'avoir était prométhéens excusez-nous
d'avoir envisagé le progrès technique
comme une avancée pour l'homme et la
deuxième qui est peut-être plus encore
forte dans notre culture européenne
c'est l'idée de la personne humaine de
la dignité de la personne humaine
peut-être que cet élément là s'est
révélé peut-être après la shoah et la
terrible confrontation du monde civilisé
de la barbarie dans un monde que nous
croyons que nous pensions civilisé eh
bien ces deux éléments là
sont-ils antagonistes non et nous
n'avons pas à être coupable comme michel
n'avons pas être coupable d'avoir eu des
colonies parce qu'à l'époque nous avions
dans la tête l'idée que nous apportions
la civilisation au monde et ne
raisonnons pas aujourd'hui avec les
idées d'hier
raisonnons aujourd'hui avec des peuples
qui sont devenus des peuples libres et
des peuples amis et pour lequel à une
certaine époque et bien nos pensions que
nous devions leur apporter plus que le
progrès merci donc d'avoir construit ce
projet
et puis après avoir rassemblé après
avoir construit un projet européen
il est venu le temps de dire et qui voit
là et merci laurent d'avoir choc choisi
françois xavier
je dis pas que tu l'a choisie tout seul
mais nous n'étions pas très nombreux et
je suis content que petit à petit
l'intelligence le savoir-faire de
françois-xavier la façon de parler
cette modération dans le ton et cette
force dans l'authenticité la profondeur
être à fond sur le fond eh bien merci
françois xavier de nous apporter à la
fois cette fraîcheur et cette profondeur
qui fait que le projet
tout d'un coup ils viennent et tiens ça
n'est pas la caricature qu'on m'avait
montré
tiens ça n'est pas le personnage que
l'on avait dénigré
non c'est un homme qui passage
excusez du peu et philosophe ça n'est
pas négligeable
ça veut dire qu'il réfléchit à un petit
peu sur ce que nous sommes et ce vers
quoi nous allons et dans ce contexte là
bien il dit des choses simples il dit
que nous sommes des déshérités
parce que nous sommes incapables de
recevoir l'héritage que nous ont apporté
l'histoire de notre pays et l'histoire
de notre civilisation
elle est née sur l'agora d'athènes en
grèce et la haine et la démocratie est
là et n'est donc l'égalité
elle est née aussi dans la chrétienneté
qui a dit celui qui est en face de toi
n'est pas ton ennemi c'est ton frère et
ce frère doit l'aimer est née la
fraternité et puis le siècle des
lumières à apporter justement ce soif de
liberté
oui je peux exprimer ma volonté je peux
exprimer ma pensée et personne n'a le
droit que je crois aussi l eau que je
n'y crois pas de dénigrer mon opinion
était née la liberté cette liberté la
france l'a portée dans tous les pays
d'europe
la portable drapeau tricolore la france
c'est la liberté et pour l'extérieur
c'est ce droit de l'homme et comme le
dirait françois xavier plus élégamment
ce droit de l'âme qui fait en sorte
effectivement la france c'est l'europe
la france c'est l'europe parce que les
cathédrales de ce seront érigés en même
temps sur l'ensemble de ce territoire et
que lorsque la flèche d'une cathédrale
bastille l'ensemble du peuple français
qu'ils croient au ciel ou qu'ils n'y
croient pas est pas capable de se lever
et de se mobiliser
et bien moi je pense que si nous sommes
là si vous êtes là c'est parce que vous
avez au fond de vous non pas envie
d'aider une liste
enfin pour que si vous le faites c'est
pas plus mal mais vous avez surtout au
fond de votre coeur deux idées fortes
voilà vous avez une certaine idée de la
france et vous avez une certaine idée de
l'homme
vous avez une certaine idée de la france
parce que vous savez que ce pays nous a
donné un héritage qu'on ne peut pas
gaspiller et qu'on doit transmettre à
nos enfants et vous avez une certaine
idée de l'homme parce que vous savez que
la personne humaine et la dignité de la
personne humaine dans son authentique
liberté doit être protégée et que nous
avons à un mot en france qui est
intraduisible dans tous les autres pays
qui s'appelle la laïcité et qui la
tolérance de la liberté de chacun
voilà pourquoi c'est avec une joie non
dissimulée que je dis aux deux hommes
qui sont en face de moi que je leur suis
très reconnaissant d'abord de dire des
choses qui vont du fond du coeur
ensuite de s'opposer au repli au la
destruction de l'europe et qu'ils sont
en train de construire patiemment non
seulement notre parti notre mouvement
mais surtout notre france et notre
europe telle que nous l'avons rêver tels
que ceux qui après la guerre se sont
rencontrés l'ont rêvé oui cette europe
des peuples et des nations
c'est en train de se construire il ya
des moments dans la vie il ya des
moments dans la vie politique
vous sentez qu'il ya un frémissement
puis un basculement ce frémissement il
peut être négatif et je vois dans vos
yeux que vous vous souvenez encore de
celui que nous avons vécue il ya deux
ans quand vous vous accrochez aux parois
et qu'elles sont lisses quand vous
essayez de convaincre et qu'on vous
tourne le dos quand vous refusez heurtée
à l'indifférence voire l'hostilité et
puis il ya des moments où le souffle
vous sentez qu'il va dans les voiles et
que le bateau va avancer et qui va
avancer parce qu'il a un bon pilote
parce qu'il a deux beaux pilote et que
ce pilotage va faire que nous allons
retrouver la confiance non pas
uniquement dans notre parti mais nous
allons retrouver confiance dans notre
civilisation est dans notre avenir
merci laurent merci franck lavier merci
à vous tous vive l'europe et vive la
france